this one mahir II but this one is Master
wrong you can see the like you see like
oh we want to want to go on a pedicure
called Bobby yeah when I found the
elongated tortoise babies after they
were hatched I was really happy they
were waving their legs I was so happy
that we had tortoise babies to mourn pay
him motya and the tortoise babies live
at the anchor center for conservation of
biodiversity or a CCB in northwestern
Cambodia Mao is a caretaker here and
starts work at 7:00 every morning with a
quick walk to make sure that everything
is in order
79 elongated tortoises hatched here
three months ago today they're going to
be weighed and measured the toolbox
contains nail polish in all colors of
the rainbow
the caretakers paint the shells of the
young tortoises to help identify where
in the conservation center they're being
kept the tortoises live in special
enclosures that are open to the sky but
with nets to help prevent them from
predators that's essential to their
survival
not long ago elongated tortoises were
upgraded to critically endangered on the
International Union for Conservation of
Nature Red List machete the Meyerhoff is
the ACC B's director he came here from
Germany more than five years ago to work
on animal conservation projects
especially ones involving birds and
turtles
there are about 360 different species of
turtle including the land tortoises what
many people don't realize is that when
the next Red List is published about 60%
of all turtles worldwide
we'll be listed as threatened endangered
or critically endangered there's a
worldwide turtle crisis right now and
Cambodia and Asia in general are no
exception long gated tortoises are
rarely sold in local markets anymore
only one of the 14 turtle species in
Cambodia is not endangered turtles are
eaten in Cambodia and used in
traditional medicine live turtles are
also sold as pets in Cambodia turtles
and tortoises are believed to bring good
fortune releasing one near a temple is
believed to bring a long life birds are
believed to carry away any bad karma
catching animals and then selling them
so they can be released is a big
business even though it's illegal when
we have Turtles here they're no longer
bought as food they're bought to be
released at temples or in lakes and
jungles otherwise they would end up in
cooking pots the small ones of a soup
while the big ones of his steam cooking
two turtles sell here for the equivalent
of five dollars what's supposed to bring
long life for believers usually spells
death for the animals after they're
released but a lucky few turtles and
tortoises end up at ACCC be like this
one it was also released at a temple
carving inside the shell you know more
like sometimes the people they scratch
something in the shell when they give it
to the month and you read it this is a
giant Asian pond turtle in this case of
relatively large mail we've received
five of these I think over the past five
years it's listed as vulnerable on the
red list we don't see them very often in
markets here in Cambodia that's hugely
the species has become relatively rare
we hardly ever get one as big as this
the team is about to operate on the
turtle it has an injury inside its shell
for the moment the animal gets a
painkiller next day Mao and her
colleague prepare food for the animals
600 turtles and tortoises live here all
of them from endangered species breeding
them in captivity has proven difficult
but the elongated tortoises appeared to
need just fresh air and food the rest
they can manage for themselves when I
started here five and a half years ago
we had about twenty elongated tortoises
thanks to our breeding program we now
have 330 at a CCB that's not a bad start
so far ACC B hasn't been able to release
any elongated tortoises into the wild
it's too dangerous
the animals would be captured again in
short order that's why Michel the
Meyerhoff is hoping to bring the
elongated tortoises here this woodland
is home to the last five large Siamese
rosewood trees in all of Southeast Asia
one tree can fetch more than 100
thousand euros this patch of forest is
under guard which could also offer
protection to the tortoises we'd like to
release the animals that are sexually
mature into the wild the ones that are
five or six years old will probably
spend the next few years carrying out
research to answer various questions for
example about their use of habitats then
we hope to launch a pilot project with
20 or 30 tortoises that will tag with a
transmitter and release into the wild
for now though the tortoises still need
the shelter of the Conservation Center
and they need Mao who is tending to them
they like to come in even in time this
why we put food even in time yeah
rent anything they like to play the
female have a lot of scratch here but
the mayor didn't have because of
marriage and the top tip you perhaps
this tortoise will be among the first
released so that one day soon a new
generation of elongated tortoises will
be born in the wild
you